as a heads up i'm going to be discussing
some spoilers for this movie since a lot
of the events towards the end are very
devoid of logic
to start out this video we have the
opening scene where an accident occurs
and in general there's a lot wrong with
this scene
firstly we have this couple getting
distracted on the road
and are veering into the other lane half
a mile down the road is an army convoy
carrying an
alpha zombie but the people leading the
convoy are also distracted because the
two guys in the front seats are talking
to each other
and apparently if you are talking to
someone in the car that means
you can't look at the road like if
you're driving a car do you just stare
someone in the eyes while talking to
them
at the very least they could have seen
the car coming from their peripheral
vision
in this shot alone their faces are being
blasted by headlights
but they just don't notice somehow also
the truck behind the leading car didn't
notice what was happening either so i
guess
no one looks at the road when they drive
these are supposed to be well-trained
soldiers
then the couple crashes into them this
head-on collision is very peculiar
because the two cars just
instantly explode on impact as if they
are both made of dynamite
that's obviously not how car crashes
work but anyways
the cargo is now detached and the person
over the radio sounds very panicked
and tells everyone to get out of there
get your men out of there
if they can't move leave them do you
understand get away from that location
now but the soldier interprets this as
to just take their time and doesn't
sound urgent whatsoever
they said to stay away from it what
and by some miracle the alpha zombie
isn't shot once
i can understand at this point in the
story that the soldiers don't know to
shoot the head
but the zombie should have been shredded
to pieces if four assault rifles
unloaded into him
but nah the zombie survives and kills
all of them
this then leads into las vegas getting
rolled by a bunch of zombies and the
government stealing off the city
all because of a chain of stupid events
later on in the story
tanaka meets scott and recruits him into
doing a heist where they are going to
take
200 million dollars from a vault in
tanaka's casino which is located in las
vegas
to prepare these mercenaries have two
full days
and access to any hardware they want
i can access any hardware you might want
but none of them
decide to get padding on their arms or
legs to prevent zombie bites
brad pitt from world war z and one scene
improvises armor on his arms by using
phone books
so this seems like a must for zombie
survival and apparently these
mercenaries have never thought about it
do these men just want to show off their
sick biceps like what's the issue here
also since they have access to anything
then wouldn't it be smart to bring
silencers for their guns
it would make sense to make as little
noise as possible given that loud noises
attract more zombies
but nah and even one of the characters
had that idea and brought a silencer
but that shouldn't really matter when
everyone else is shooting their guns
without silencers thus making a lot of
noise
and i know silencers are technically
kind of loud in real life but in
movies and video games they're portrayed
to be pretty quiet
so upon getting to the refugee camp
outside of las vegas
we have a scene where kate ward figures
out that a family she cares about was
escorted by this coyote
into las vegas and the family did not
come back
fashionably kate has a meltdown and
wants to go with the team to save the
family
in this moment she comes off as a whiny
brat and she says to scott
her father that he only has two options
let me come with you or i go myself
like no i think there's a third option
in which we zip tie you to one of the
buses that are leaving the area since a
nuke is coming
then after that moment scott caves and
agrees for her to tag along
this completely belittles scott's
character because he gets stepped on by
his own daughter who publicly shamed him
in front of his own crew
it's kind of hard to be a badass leader
when this cringy character takes a [ __ ]
on you
so moving ahead to where the team is now
on their way to the casino we have a
scene where they run into a group of
hibernating zombies
during the scene we figure out that
martin the casino head of security
wants to screw everyone over and here he
screws over
chambers this leads to a really cool
john wick zombie slaying sequence where
she kills dozens of zombies
and surprisingly survives she manages to
partially escape and gets back to the
group
but there are a few zombies that
overwhelm her and for some idiotic
reason
no one helps her there's literally
multiple guys with assault rifles that
can easily save her here
even her friend was just staring at her
and instead of helping her
he just waits and puts her out of her
misery in this
instance no one has a motive to not save
chambers
her entire cut is split with this guy
and by letting her die
it's not like everyone else will get a
higher cut due to having one less crew
member to pay
also another stupid thing about this
scene is that when she gets caught by
the zombies
she doesn't shout out to the group that
she was betrayed by martin
instead she just sits there quietly
staring at everyone awkwardly and dies
oh well i guess martin now has free
reign to screw over the group again
thanks to chambers
so moving along for the scene where the
characters tried to get into the vault
it was all around pretty ridiculous it
starts off with a weird segment where
they see a prior dead team who tried to
crack the vault before them
that was sent by tanaka who for some
reason has the same exact clothes as
them
and it's completely unexplained in the
movie they just play it off as a joke
and it basically just breaks the fourth
wall
this seems like zack sanders just
messing around with the viewers unless
it is one big time loop
but the story doesn't really paint that
picture especially by the end
after that the vault apparently has
booby traps
as if this is some kind of ancient ruin
in indiana jones
to counter this they decided to bring in
a live zombie to walk through the
pressure plates
but that's just inherently dumb because
a zombie should just turn around and go
after the humans
it would have been much more logical to
just throw one of the skeletons i set up
a minute ago
onto one of the traps thus sending them
off but
they go through an overtly convoluted
way to set them off with live
zombies albeit it's a little funnier
because of that
another aspect about this scene that's
illogical is that it doesn't come off as
a red flag to our characters
that tanaka didn't mention there being
lethal traps leading up to his vaults
that seems pretty suspicious to me and
in what world would someone make a
barbaric system like this
what happened to just setting off an
alarm and getting detained by security
i know this is meant to just be campy
and funny but regardless
it's pretty stupid for the vault opening
itself
the safecracker says he needs silence
but then everyone starts talking and
even using a loud money counting machine
i need silence money machine go bear
also why do they even need a
professional safe cracker to begin with
shouldn't tanaka have an easier way to
open the vault given that he owns
it does he not know his own combination
instead we have this cartoony character
who has some kind of vault fetish
and then there's also the aspect of how
does this crappy little helicopter carry
200 million dollars in cash
along with eight people the 200 million
dollars alone would weigh about
4 400 pounds or 2.2 tons
and with the additional weight of
everyone else in the helicopter that
thing would never leave the ground
and don't worry the snowball of
stupidity keeps rolling from there
because there's 20 minutes until the new
kids because to make this even more
tense the president decided to move the
nuke launch up a day
we got about 20 minutes for this place
to dust and then our characters waste a
lot of time celebrating
and even having a heartwarming scene
where one of the characters professes
their love to scots
i thought we could have had something
like what are you guys doing
you need to pick up the pace or you're
all going to die
then a few minutes later martin betrays
everyone and locks him in the ball area
his plan all along was to instead get a
sample of an alpha zombie to which him
and tanaka would sell for a much higher
price than the money in the vaults
however this whole plan bleeds stupidity
the way in which they execute this plan
is overtly convoluted and is completely
counterproductive
why doesn't tanaka just make the plan to
only extract the alpha's head and call
it a day
why even include the bank vault at that
point it had significantly more risk
and the zombie head is worth much more
anyways also
they literally run into the alpha when
they first enter the city
all they had to do was subdue the alpha
cut off her head and then
immediately leave after that it would
have taken them like 10 minutes
why are these generals even going to
tanaka in the first place to get an
alpha zombie head
why not just go directly to the
mercenaries who know the terrain and can
deal with the zombies
it's not like extracting the zombie head
is particularly bad or anything
it's just going back to the us military
in which one of the alphas came from
initially it would make more sense for
the heroes to be hesitant to work with
tanaka if he was trying to sell the
zombie head to a hostile foreign power
which would thus lead tanaka to want to
lie to the heroes but that's not the
case
but anyways going back to the scene
where martin locks everyone in the vault
area his plan is to go up to the roof
and take the helicopter
so why did he end up going outside
towards the front of the casino then
i guess this character just develops
amnesia within one minute
and forgets his goal on the effort so
that the filmmakers can have a forced
action scene with a zombie tiger
if they really wanted a scene with a
zombie tiger just include it in the
casino action scene where the rest of
the characters tried to get back to the
helicopter
i think it would have been pretty cool
if he had dave pautista wrestling it but
that's just me
wait was that a robot zombie are we just
not going to talk about that
so later the characters get out of the
casino and make it to the roof while
being pursued by the king alpha zombie
the coyote said that she knows what
she's doing and has a gun to the queen's
head
but what was actually her plan here she
wasn't trying to get onto the helicopter
and instead of just going to stay on the
rooftop with the king zombie
that seems pretty suicidal and it
obviously doesn't work out for her
i just don't know what her plan was
especially since she was one of the
smartest characters in the movie
up to that point then we have that
annoying sequence where scott has to go
save his daughter
because she went on a wild use chase to
find that missing family
and very conveniently she somehow finds
them within like
10 minutes i don't know how she knew the
family was in this very specific
building
or even how she was able to find them in
all the rooms and floors
also i don't know why the king zombie
didn't just turn this family into alphas
but
oh well i guess these people have plot
armor so that this can even exist in the
first place
then scott gets to the building via the
helicopter and tells the pallet to wait
for him
upon arriving back to the roof with his
daughter and the family the pilot did
not stay for them
but then the pilot just comes back like
this pilot went through all the trouble
of taking off
and leaving to just suddenly change
their minds the nuke is about to hit in
a few minutes so the pilot should have
just
gotten the hell out of there if she was
smart from a filmmaking perspective why
even
include this whole moment in the movie
it's basically just a waste of time
just have the pilot stay and then we
wouldn't have this awkward dialogue that
adds nothing
then as they are escaping the nuke hits
vegas and takes a helicopter down
i can buy them surviving the helicopter
crash but surviving a nuke within a
couple miles of distance is
utter nonsense zack steiner doesn't know
how nukes work apparently and these
people would literally be cooking in
radiation and would die
very quickly according to kyrgyzstan
if you were within eight miles of a nuke
you'd essentially burst into flames from
the sheer
heat of the explosion but these people
somehow survive
also the family they rescued was in the
helicopter but we don't see
them after the crash so did they survive
the movie implies that they survived
because scott gives money to his
daughter to give to that family
but we don't see them after the initial
crash
i mean it wouldn't really matter anyways
because they should all die from
radiation poisoning within a few days
so that money would be no good then
before the movie ends
van der hoe survives because earlier he
was thrown into the casino vault while
they got ambushed by zombies
and there are quite a few aspects that
don't make sense about this whole
scenario
so van der rohe emerges from the vault
and enters the now demolished las vegas
in reality he should immediately start
getting rolled by radiation
from this i don't even think he'd be
able to get to the mini airport he is
able to travel to in this whole scene
on top of his arm being dislocated and
him somehow being able to carry a large
bag of money for miles
however this doesn't matter because it
is later revealed that he had a zombie
bite all along
you're telling me that this man didn't
even notice that he got bit or even felt
the pain
on his arm while having the bite then
there's the whole issue of how long it
takes for you to turn when you have a
zombie bite
in the beginning of the movie the
soldiers turn in under a minute
for scott since he was bit by the king
zombie on the helicopter
he ends up turning about 5-10 minutes
later which
is acceptable going back to vanderhoe
though he seems to go numerous
hours without turning so in this regard
it seems as though the filmmakers use
the time it takes to turn into a zombie
at their own convenience for the story
because if it actually took a few
minutes then
van der hoe would have just turned into
a zombie while in the vaults
and this stupid cliffhanger would have
never happened
so yeah that's army of the dead i can
see a lot of people defending this movie
by saying
you're taking this movie way too
seriously and it's meant to just be dumb
fun well in regards to that
only like 30 minutes of the movie was
actually fun and the rest of it was
trying to be really serious
if the script actually made more sense
and wasn't riddled with plot holes then
this movie would undoubtedly be much
better
but as it stands there's a lot of devoid
of logic aspects about it
thank you for watching and if you liked
this video i've made other devoid of
logic videos on game of thrones
wonder woman 1984 and the rise of
skywalker just to name a few
have a good day and let me know what you
thought about army of the dead in the
comments